okay so since we did the other video of
the 13 people versus one model one last
question what's the first thing you know
first thing I noticed be honest
completely honest because your ick was
it oh that real
[Applause]
there was intensity there which was good
made me question his misogynistic
mindset though with the last comment but
we can we'll see you asked
you oh
have you ever been with a black woman
before I have you have why is that a red
flag
it's kind of giving Jungle Fever
I don't know I like your smile wow so
you think I'm ugly stop stop stop stop
stop stop stop stop I figured we'd do
the other version with the sex the Sexes
reversed
[Music]
there's a lot of black people in this
video yeah I didn't know Australia had
black people I didn't know Australia had
black people too yeah technically
speaking most of Australia doesn't have
people period Fair the middle part yeah
they're the things I don't give you
death yeah death yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah Australia is just a swirl of death
and kangaroos hey I'm Jacob I'm the 22.
um if I tell you a joke and you swipe
right will you laugh
if I tell you a joke and you laugh at
least one right
okay I asked the Frenchman if you played
video games and he said we
hi
yeah hey you look really fresh today
thank you yeah what's your name malayka
what's her name Williams William yeah so
I was just gonna say like you know roses
are red violets are blue
uh baby girl I've never seen someone
look so fine like you
I'm sorry
it's corny but he tried okay yeah in
compared to the other video these people
are actually trying he tried that's two
on two hi hi
you said
oh sorry that was French it was just
really beautiful [ __ ] I speak French
and I don't know what the [ __ ] you said
I heard I thought and he went
and then I said bro that was not French
that was something straight out of
Uganda all right
mushroom fish
usually oh my God you say what yeah
try it again take that Campbell noodle
soup out of here because I heard no no
he was mumbling he was mumbling he's the
Migos yes reincarnated rest in peace
well I can't I can't do that
I'm gonna say no because of the shoes
I'm sorry I knew it she really looked at
him and went what are those news
get the [ __ ] up there's a baffle bite of
that was not French that was our first
my man tried to play us bro
um what's your name
my name is uh your boy Chang
um if you let me uh go through I'll take
you to the movies
you know
bro
I live in you know what I mean that's
what it did what's your name I like how
was your name my name is your boy Chang
um if you let me um go through I'll take
you to the movies
foreign
[Music]
and then we're gonna have a good time
it's not even lighting up yeah it's your
boy Chang you know what I'm saying
exactly the point it's not lighting up
is your boy King
[Music]
let's go watch the movies
[Laughter]
hey man listen yo these guys
I I I'm starting to sympathize is that
it yeah because you know you know what
they say like let me take it to the
movie shot
he did a remix to the candy shop
yes he said let me take you to the movie
shot
disappointing yo bro I'm sorry yo ladies
straight ladies today I'm on your side
okay every man is on your side right now
straight vomit you look so familiar are
you sure in the same class
in the same class yeah I could have
thought we had chemistry together
wow that was a good one you know howdy
take a guess
28th a little lower but we're working
23.
slightly lower all right I do I'm gonna
say no just because I've heard that one
before I'm sorry no no no no no no no no
no no no that's cap that's cap fast cap
it was the age that threw you off that's
cat hey
what's your name
yeah sorry
uh but uh so there's nothing much for me
to say you see this
I've kept this since I was a little kid
just imagine how long I'll keep you you
know
what are you gonna do
today
you're gone no they're done right here
no no no
yeah
he went I told you all right it's
already done it's already done I [ __ ]
it up
yeah hold on no I'm not gonna let you
give me the L I'll go get it myself
thank you yeah yeah all right what's up
hey let's go ahead
and how are you doing okay how are you
okay why does this guy sound like [ __ ]
you know when you come out the subway
stations like so have you heard of Jesus
Christ yes good yes he's the greatest
isn't he good have you found salvation
in your life yet no fantastic okay well
let's come over here how do you have a
conversation I'll just take a minute of
your time sir why is this energy so
weird he looks like a missionary doesn't
he yeah it's a little bit about yourself
about me yeah that is what I call I'm
20.
I'm here today okay yeah what do you
want to know um I should be I'm supposed
to be getting to know you yeah
what do you want to know
how old are you oh yeah no that guy is
the guy version of the girls yeah we'll
get this dweeb out of here bro let me
just skip ahead
hi how you doing good how are you God
damn
let's get your dimples from
I don't know my grandpa yeah
okay I mean are you indoor or like
outdoor person but yeah so what was
Lifeline technique huh where would you
like to go if I'll take you out
my bad thing because you came to the
suit he already closed the deal brother
you at the negotiating table and you
didn't bring nothing this morning he
said where would you like to take me how
about I take you to the left to the left
because you need to go this [ __ ]
is just like a car salesman acting like
the car being sold
calm down she said where would you like
to take me where would you take me
perhaps Society you know maybe take out
them Jordans put you back in some hills
or something you know
what the [ __ ]
he said out of the Jordans into some
heels Got What whose mans is this
yeah okay now who's next Who's man's is
this yo get him out of here just say
that again and I'm wrong you know but
yeah I'm just gonna say yes because I
love the effort for this outfit so thank
you look that's just here today
hi good how are you
you got white friends right white
friends yeah I do all right so I left if
you let your boyfriend say to him
so I've left if I say if my white
friends can say the N word yeah well
then I said no so yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
he tried to trick her into swiping right
the swiping left because over there
swiping left means yes yeah
so he said swag
he said swipe light swipe left if you
let your friends say the N word she
doesn't so she swiped right which means
get up yeah so this she brought the
level of disappointment I'm feeling
right now Australia uh apparently your
men ain't got no games yeah but the the
trying but I heard that though
Australian men have no game heard that
from Australian chicks oh yeah
uh my name is Daniel I'm 21. um swipe
left if you think billum's okay
no no no now you guys are using the same
[ __ ] [ __ ] wow you know what you know
what ladies in Australia I gotta
apologize these dudes are cornier than
y'all
so all everything that happened last
video I'm starting to understand it
what's up with these guys I can't
understand that every Jubilee video
obviously new comparison doesn't even
come close this is way prettier yeah hey
everybody in the comment section right
now can we all just appreciate Australia
no risk No Game No ability to seduce I
really thought the man here had no game
oh my God what the guys over there
[ __ ] and she gonna swipe left on him
because he's cute
I was gonna swipe you right anyway
you're cute
um what's your name
my name is uh your boy Chang
um if you let me um go through I'll take
you to the movies
um you know
bro hold on you know what to do when the
dude hits this but it isn't she you know
what I mean that's what it did you know
because of his name is what he said hey
uh it's your boy Chang uh I hope like
there's no way that's it yeah you said
that hi how you going what's your name
Malika hey I'm Malika I'm Patrick
Patrick you're fit as hell do you do any
boxing no because you're a damn knockout
see homeboy for the last video said he
got game we showed it
hello hi my name is Simba your name is
a pleasure to meet you Malika
um I'm a producer I uh
spend all my time in the studio pretty
much about spiritual stuff I'd like to
get to know you a bit better
okay
I think that will sound good you know
someone named Simba
and I'm sorry
we have come to make a decision we have
left Pride Rock and you have come back
looking like you have come from a pride
festival you have brought the sun on our
family we do not want you back eh we
need a king not a queen
yeah I've made the wrong decision Cisco
leave their boat oh my God hey my friend
said come here a spirituality ah my
spirit has left my body as I'm gazing
upon you I've felt shame of the highest
order the man came he said my name is
Simba for what reason eh
for what reason
this is deviant Behavior stop it it's
your boy
good how are you
my name is
and I'll call you the one
I'm sorry
you can't really
hey my man thought he was in a Bollywood
movie and he was the main actor my name
is rizwan I found out he's an unnamed
character in the [ __ ] credits my
friend
no you gotta go
hi oh hi hi what's your name Malaika I
like this my name is Santino I can't buy
you I can't I can't call you beautiful I
can't buy you I can't I can't call you
[ __ ]
[Applause]
hey my name is my name is
my my name is Jimmy my name is Jim and I
can I can I can I can do it if you let
me do it to you
let me do it to you good I've got it in
my citizenship
in my uh my uh my my my name is Jim
foreign
[Music]
I can't call you beautiful because
you're beautiful beauty beauty is on the
inside and I don't know you and I
haven't been inside yet so uh for for
research purposes
[Music]
please let me inside you
please please
let me do it please
oh that's good
where are the diamonds where where are
the diamonds
what is the problem huh where did
diamonds tell me my friend you cannot
tell me to swipe I said you are not the
captain this is me and I'm the captain
now oh my God hi hey how are you good
how are you all right my name is Joe
what's your name my man came dressed
like a prison didn't make that found
Islam straight up
straight up a prison inmate that found
Islam straight from the commissioner he
did the commissary he's
done
yeah
I don't know your name but the skills
you miss I see you from across the room
s
yay
girl girl you know what I mean you gotta
get it
you gotta get ready
yay yeah
that's why everybody's up and I got a
man she got my answers you make me wanna
say yeah I'll see how you going
hey yeah girl yeah
if it was Chris Brown in one of his
dances do it again
yay yay got a beautiful smile thank you
thank you
I didn't come here for the videos I came
here for you you came in for me
as I say I know I was gonna find love
today and I think I found it really
yeah ladies if any dude comes this
strong onto you and talks to this [ __ ]
there's no he's gonna [ __ ] you and leave
you without a doubt okay
any dude who comes on this strong off
the top is 100 lying at his [ __ ]
this man with a straight face and he's
here for love and he's ready man shut
the [ __ ] up
right can we give me stop this
audience I think we need to stop yeah
we're good what am I taking away from
this a lot of dudes Ain't Got Game
especially in Australia Jesus Christ
we've watched a lot of these dating
videos and this is easily the worst one
in terms of games absolutely they were
super lame horrible all the cast horrid
Oh my days now maybe they weren't as
dislikable in terms like hate ability
because they weren't insufferable like
yeah they were just so [ __ ] boring
and bad they were dope yeah so so there
you guys have it you guys wanted us to
cover the second half see what the
fellas did we showed we're not doing it
well we showed us as much as we can
handle yeah and uh yeah anything else
you want no no don't do it don't do it